herr frei sie konnten vielleicht das
gespräch mit verfolgen und auch die
stimmen auf diesen demonstrationen wie
umgehen mit den menschen ja das ist
wirklich eine sehr schwierige und
komplizierte frage weil wir erleben dass
die pandemie immer stärker jetzt auch
zur bewährungsprobe für die demokratie
wird wir erleben eine zunehmenden
zuspitzung in der debatte und wir
erleben eine unversöhnlichkeit auf beim
protest gegen die vorgesehenen
schutzmassnahmen wie wir das bisher
glaube ich so noch nie erlebt haben und
das ist schon ein problem bei dem ich
glaube dass der staat jedenfalls klare
kante zeigen muss es muss klar sein in
der demokratie ist widerspruch ist
protest selbstverständlich erlaubt aber
das hat immer auch gewissen regeln zu
folgen das gilt auch im
demonstrationsrecht es gilt auch in der
frage wie man sich verhält und wenn ich
mir die demonstrationen in den letzten
tagen anschauen wo polizisten massiv
körperlich angegangen worden sind muss
man einfach sagen da ist spätestens eine
grenze überschritten die der staat nicht
akzeptieren kann und wo wir uns deshalb
auch überlegen müssen wie wir sichtbare
zeichen setzen er frei aber das versteht
sich ja von selbst wenn ich das so sagen
darf dass der klare kante gezeigt werden
muss und dass man gewalt nicht
akzeptieren kann aber das problem ist ja
defizite und liegt tiefer wie wir gerade
gehört haben von unseren reportern da
sind ja auch einfach menschen die angst
haben die einfach nur skeptisch sind und
die dann sowie die biermann unser
reporter es beschrieben hat sozusagen
sich infizieren was die meinungen und
was verschwörungstheorien angeht man
muss doch dort ansetzen
den job muss an beiden stellen ansetzen
also für diejenigen die gewalttätig sind
ist es glaube ich wichtig dass man ihnen
ein stück weit auch die maske herunter
reist über beschleunigten verfahren es
tatsächlich auch zu strafverfahren
kommen lässt damit trifft man glaube ich
auch viele die an solchen
demonstrationen teilnehmen und sich dort
straftaten schuldig machen auf der
anderen seite sie haben das folgende
gespräch auch angesprochen geht es darum
dass du internet das soziale netzwerke
das messenger dienste nicht zur
verbreitung von hass und hetze
missbraucht werden dafür haben wir das
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz gemacht
und auch novelliert und wir erleben
beispielsweise bei den messenger-dienst
telegramm das eben regelungen dort auch
ganz gezielt umgangen werden weil es
eben nicht nur ein messenger dienst ist
sondern im wesentlichen auch ein
netzwerk wo sich tausende zehntausende
hunderttausende
auch verabreden und opas und hitze
propagiert wird der weg hoch schätzen
sie denn diese gefahr ein auch die
gefahr dass sich diese gruppe von
menschen weiter radikalisiert durch
austausch von falschinformationen
diese gefahr besteht ganz eindeutig weil
sie sich ja weitestgehend auch in einer
eigenen blase befinden das gilt virtuell
digital das gilt aber mit sicherheit
auch auf diesen demonstrationen
das ist keine einheitliche gruppe von
menschen das ist eine ganz
unterschiedliche herkunft auch eine ganz
unterschiedliche ideologische
unterfütterung aber sie bewegen sich
sozusagen in der gleichen klasse sie
stacheln sich gegenseitig auf und das
ist schon sehr sehr gefährlich weil sie
dann eben das haben ja ihre beiden
reporter auch gezeigt die argumente im
grunde nicht mehr zugänglich sind das
ist aber die grundvoraussetzung für den
demokratischen diskurs
ja das sind erklärungen herr frey
lösungen allerdings sind das noch nicht
ja da haben sie vollkommen recht ich
habe bedauerlicherweise auch kein
patentrezept
was wir erleben ist natürlich dass
debatten um weitere schließungen um eine
mögliche impfpflicht zur polarisierung
in der gesellschaft beitragen das lässt
sich aber auch nicht verhindern wir sind
in einer großen krise die wir zu
bewältigen haben das macht unangenehme
entscheidungen notwendig das muss man
ganz offen zu kommunizieren und wir
werden in unserer gesellschaft formen
finden müssen wie wir den austausch den
gesellschaftlichen diskurs organisieren
ohne dass es arbeit zu verletzten kommt
das muss möglich seien und das muss man
von mündigen bürgern auch ein stück weit
aber das sagt thorsten frei innenexperte
der cdu vielen herzlichen dank ihnen für
das gespräch
sehr gerne